Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonjour à toutes et à tous.
Devinez quelle est la personne que vous
voyez là de face, en un combat acharné,
sans air et territoire boueux,
copieusement arrosé par les anciens ?
Oui, bien sûr, c’est moi
quand je suis rentré à Centrale Supélec
il y a quelques années.
Voilà. (Rit)
À la sortie de l’école,
entre le nucléaire et l’informatique,
j’ai choisi l’informatique.
J'y suis encore.
Je souhaite aborder avec vous
un sujet qui me préoccupe beaucoup
dans mes activités professionnelles
et qui nous concerne tous.
Quelle peut être la place de l’Europe
dans l’industrie mondiale
du numérique en 2030 ?
En 2022, l'Europe du numérique
est malade, très malade.
Le risque que l’Europe devienne
un acteur marginal de cette industrie
mondiale du numérique
augmente tous les jours.
Peut-on encore redresser la barre ?
Sur ce sujet chaud, brûlant,
j’ai des positions fortes
en opposition frontale avec un très grand
nombre de décideurs des mondes politiques,
économiques et numériques.
Le numérique est omniprésent
dans vos activités, dans mes activités.
Il peut parfois créer
des dépendances fortes -
des dépendances fortes.
L’industrie automobile européenne
a été incapable
de fabriquer des millions de véhicules
en 2021 alors que la demande était forte.
Pourquoi ?
Elle a subi une pénurie mondiale
de composants électroniques.
Le groupe Renault a perdu
500 000 ventes en 2021
et cette pénurie va continuer en 2023.
Et l’Europe ?
80% des usines qui fabriquent
ces composants électroniques
sont situées en Corée du Sud ou à Taïwan.
Les fondeurs.
Le numérique est aussi porteur de positif.
La société Moderna,
vous la connaissez tous.
Elle est basée à Boston.
Mais son président, Stéphane Bancel,
est français.
Devinez
quelle était sa formation initiale.
Centrale Supélec, bien sûr.
Moderna, créée en 2010,
travaille depuis cette époque
sur les technologies d’ARN messager.
Décembre 2019, on commence
à parler de la Covid-19.
Janvier 2020,
en toute urgence,
Moderna modifie ses plans d’action
pour mettre ses compétences
dans les ARN messagers
au service de la création
d’un vaccin contre la Covid-19.
Pour accélérer cette recherche,
Moderna s’appuie sur les ressources Cloud
computing - Infrastructure As A Service -
du leader mondial AWS,
Amazon Web Services.
Le résultat ?
Le résultat :
42 jours pour créer ce vaccin.
Un vaccin créé en 42 jours.
Les personnes de Moderna estiment que si
elles n'avaient pas eu le cloud computing,
il leur aurait fallu 20 mois.
Un gain de temps de 18 mois.
On estime aujourd’hui qu’il y a eu
à peu près 6,5 millions de morts
liés à la Covid-19 dans le monde.
Essayez d’imaginer
le nombre de millions de [vies]
qui ont été sauvées
par ce gain de temps de 18 mois.
Merci le cloud computing.
Merci le numérique.
L’industrie du numérique
est une industrie mondiale.
Elle est dominée aujourd’hui par deux
grands pays, les États-Unis et la Chine,
qui se livrent un combat acharné
pour en assurer le leadership.
En 2022,
les États-Unis font encore
la course en tête.
De nombreux experts, dont je fais partie,
estiment que la Chine aura dépassé
les États-Unis en 2030.
Et l’Europe, où en est-elle en 2022 ?
La situation, en un mot :
préoccupante.
La situation en deux mots :
espoir raisonnable.
Voilà.
Comment ?
L’Europe a encore heureusement
quelques domaines où elle est aujourd’hui
avec des positions de force.
Prenons un exemple : la société SAP,
allemande, est numéro trois mondial
des logiciels d’entreprise.
Face à cette situation préoccupante, j'ai
imaginé quatre réponses possibles.
Fanfaronnade.
Bureaucratie.
Désespoir.
Pragmatisme.
Fanfaronnade.
C’est parfaitement illustré
par cet entretien de M. Cédric O.
À l’époque, il était secrétaire d’État
au numérique en France.
Il disait :
« C’est le moment pour faire de l’Europe
le 1er territoire technologique mondial. »
Deuxième scénario : bureaucratie.
L’Europe est très bonne dans de très
nombreux domaines avec la bureaucratie.
Nous en avons une illustration
exceptionnelle dans le numérique.
L’Europe a créé en avril 2020
une association, Gaia-X,
dont l’objectif est de créer
un cloud souverain européen.
Vingt-deux membres à sa création ;
ils sont 320 aujourd’hui.
Comme vous le voyez
sur cette liste partielle des membres,
tous les grands acteurs américains
du numérique sont dans Gaia-X :
IBM, Microsoft, Oracle, Amazon
et beaucoup d'autres.
Alors...
Troisième scénario :
le désespoir.
L’Europe du numérique est foutue.
Elle n’a pas les moyens
de créer une industrie numérique
compétitive au niveau mondial.
Nous sommes condamnés
à être les vassaux de la Chine
et des États-Unis.
Ce n’est pas un scénario
que j’ai envie de défendre.
L’Europe a encore de beaux combats
numériques à faire et à gagner.
Tout n'est pas perdu.
Encore faut-il bien choisir ses combats.
Et ceci m’amène à la quatrième solution,
celle que je défends : le pragmatisme.
L’Europe doit accepter le fait
qu’il y a des combats numériques
que nous avons perdus définitivement.
Un exemple : le cloud computing,
l’infrastructure as a service.
La société américaine Gartner publie
ce qu’on appelle des quadrants magiques
où elle positionne
les grands acteurs du secteur.
Dans le quadrant magique
de l’Infrastructure as a service,
vous trouvez les trois grands leaders
américains, Amazon, Google, Microsoft,
trois chinois, Alibaba, Tencent et Huawei,
deux anciens combattants américains,
IBM et Oracle.
Et l’Europe ?
Missing in action.
Cet échec catastrophique de l’Europe
dans le domaine du cloud computing
est illustré de façon exceptionnelle
par ce graphique.
Entre 2017 et 2022,
le marché européen du cloud
a été multiplié par quatre.
C'est une belle croissance.
Sur cette même période, la part
des Européens a été divisée par deux.
Autre domaine dans lequel le combat est
difficile : l’intelligence artificielle.
Entre 2012 et 2020,
les investissements dans des start-ups
de l’intelligence artificielle
ont grandi de manière exponentielle,
comme vous le voyez sur ce graphique.
En 2020, États-Unis plus Chine
représentent 80% de ces investissements.
L’Europe des 27,
7%.
Autant que le Royaume-Uni.
Il est grand temps de passer au positif.
L’Europe a des domaines
dans lesquels elle peut gagner.
Composants électroniques.
L’Europe a un leader mondial que
très peu de personnes connaissent :
ASML.
Combien de personnes dans la salle
connaissent cette entreprise
basée aux Pays-Bas ?
Levez la main.
Bravo !
ASML est le premier fabricant mondial
de machines de lithographie,
comme celle que vous voyez là.
ASML est le seul fabricant mondial
de machines de lithographie
capables de faire de la lithographie
en nanomètres.
Le prix d’une machine
comme celle que vous voyez
est équivalent de celui d'un Airbus A320.
Il y a en Europe d’autres entreprises
qui ont des positions fortes
dans le domaine des circuits électroniques
comme STMicroelectronics ou Soitec.
Et l’Europe a bien réagi -
bravo ! -
en annonçant au début 2022
le European Chip Act,
avec un investissement
de 50 milliardsd’euros.
Et, une fois n’est pas coutume, l’Europe
est en avance sur les États-Unis.
Il a fallu attendre août 2022
pour que les États-Unis annoncent
leur Chips and Science Act
avec un montant équivalent
de 50 milliardsde dollars.
L’Europe est aussi extrêmement performante
dans un domaine des logiciels de
nouvelle génération qu’on appelle SAAS -
Software As A Service -
qui sont pour l’essentiel
construits sur les cloud américains.
Il y a en Europe plus
d’une centaine de licornes,
des entreprises valorisées
plus d’un milliard de dollars.
Et comme vous le voyez là,
la France est bien placée.
Il y en a beaucoup que vous connaissez
comme Doctolib, Blablacar, Deezer,
et quelques autres.
L’Europe doit aussi investir
rapidement et massivement
dans des domaines du numérique
où tout reste à inventer.
Eh oui, il en reste et heureusement.
J’en prendrai un exemple :
les solutions numériques
au service des équipes terrain.
De quoi s’agit-il ?
Ce sont les travailleurs essentiels
dont le rôle-clé a été mis en évidence
pendant la pandémie de Covid-19.
Ils représentent les trois quarts
de la population qui travaille :
transports, restauration, hôtellerie,
industrie, agriculture, logistique.
Ce sont toutes les personnes
qui ne peuvent pas télétravailler.
Ce sont aussi, hélas,
les grands oubliés de la
transformation numérique aujourd’hui.
80% des budgets numériques
des entreprises
sont réservés aux cols blancs,
aux équipes bureau, vous et moi.
20%,
20% seulement
pour les travailleurs terrain.
Tout reste à faire pour inventer
des solutions numériques
qui répondent aux véritables attentes
de ces équipes terrain.
Et elles sont totalement différentes de
celles des personnes dans les bureaux.
L’Europe peut donc devenir
rapidement un leader mondial
dans les solutions numériques SAAS
au service des équipes terrain.
Que fait une personne comme moi
qui a une forte culture d’entrepreneur
quand elle découvre un marché
qui a beaucoup de potentiel ?
Elle crée une start-up.
C'est ce que j'ai fait en 2018.
Cette start-up propose
une solution universelle
pour tous travailleur terrain
qui lit le contenu d’une photo avec un
smartphone pour éliminer les formulaires.
Elle embarque beaucoup
d’intelligence artificielle.
Cette solution est valable
pour tous les travailleurs terrain,
quel que soit leur métier,
leur secteur d’activité, leur pays,
et, bien sûr, au-delà des frontières.
C'est une première mondiale.
Oui, vous aussi vous pouvez
en 2021 en Europe,
créer des sociétés nouvelles
dans le numérique qui ont
qui ont vocation et capacité
à devenir des leaders mondiaux.
Dans ce domaine,
il y a une information
qui m’a beaucoup bouleversé,
que je voudrais partager avec vous.
J'ai une question pour vous.
Dans le monde entier,
quel est le pourcentage des enfants
qui sortent de l’école primaire
et qui sont incapables
de comprendre un texte qu’ils lisent ?
Quel est ce pourcentage ?
48%.
C'est un scandale absolu.
À quoi a servi l’UNESCO depuis 50 ans ?
48% des personnes sont illettrées.
À ne pas confondre avec analphabètes.
48% des personnes sont incapables
d'utiliser les outils numériques existants
qui sont tous basés sur le texte.
Quels étaient dans l’humanité,
avant l’invention de l’écriture,
les outils de communication ?
Le dessin et la voix.
Aujourd’hui,
depuis un smartphone,
avec la photo et la voix,
on peut créer des applications
qui vont permettre de régler
la plus grande fracture numérique
qui existe dans le monde,
entre le monde du bureau
et le monde du terrain.
Faire rentrer dans le numérique
des milliards de personnes,
c’est un beau défi, vous ne trouvez pas ?
J’ai commencé mon exposé
en vous posant une question :
quelle peut être la place de l’Europe
dans cette industrie mondiale
du numérique en 2030 ?
La réponse, je l’ai trouvée dans
le seul atout principal de l’Europe :
ses talents, ses compétences,
ses merveilleux ingénieurs
français et européens.
Ce sont les nouvelles
promotions de Central Supélec
et bien sûr d’autres écoles et universités
françaises et européennes.
Vous êtes l'avenir du numérique européen.
On entend beaucoup parler aujourd’hui
de l’expression
« souveraineté numérique européenne ».
Je suis un grand partisan de cette
souveraineté numérique européenne.
Mais pour réussir
cette souveraineté numérique,
l’Europe ne doit pas gaspiller ses talents
dans des combats perdus d’avance.
L’Europe doit choisir les combats
qu’elle veut mener dans le numérique
dans les prochaines années.
Alors oui,
si on suit ces règles simples,
l’Europe pourra garder
une place raisonnable
dans l’industrie mondiale
du numérique en 2030.
Merci.